hey what's going on as bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast and just checking in on you I'm
just checking it on your hello this is
Susan blooms Dean Corll Inc that's a
character I used to call up a buddy of
mine all the time I pretend to be his
casting director and I would just call
him up with the worst [__] auditions
ever hello this is Susan blooms Dean
Corll Inc I have an audition for you
it's for a feature do you have a problem
with being naked around other men in
positions that involves you staring at
your ankles if you have a problem you
cool stupid [__] like that it was always
like you know something that I guess
would be considered homophobic is
instead of just being funny you know is
it homophobic to suggest that he would
be uncomfortable staring at his ankle
ankles I should say in the company of
other men I don't know what's going on
how was your Thursday did you get paid
today huh did they write some numbers on
a piece of paper and then you stuck it
in a machine and somehow you can get
waffles it's all the money's in the air
now I don't know where it is you know
safe to say either some white dude has
all of it Russian dude which is guess is
a white tube but white dude means
American to it right or English right
Russian dude or Chinese dude one of
them's got it maybe somebody in
Singapore has all the money with
Japanese guy and of course you got the
[__] Saudi princess they got
something like six people have it all
right now and the rest of us just get
pieces of paper with numbers on it but
as long as we believe in it no matter
what they say on TV no matter how bad
they say it's getting as long as we just
continue to [__] believe in it just
keep writing numbers to each other right
next thing you know I got a shirt you
got a taco everybody's happy Susan Blum
Steen calling
anyways so here's what's going on with
me last night
me and the lovely Nia my beautiful leg
we went down and saw Iggy Pop he has a
new album out the post pop depression
and basically like 90% of Queens of the
Stone Age was backing him up
John Theodore was not on drums but it
was pretty much I think the rest of the
band and Iggy Pop came out it was
[__] amazing show
I lucked into these tickets I was doing
a comedy show I ran into somebody that
works for the band they said we got it a
couple extra tickets do you want to go
my freckle stood up at attention and of
course I went I went down there and
goddamnit what an amazing show Sarah
Silverman opened up she [__] crushed
it and Iggy Pop man there's a bucket
list right there bucket list one to go
see the guy [__] comes out there.i
he's got on a sports coat with no shirt
underneath it he's 68 years old
all right after one song the coat is
gone and he's prancing around with no
shirt on 68 years old it's the [__]
[__] guy just doesn't give a [__] I'm
gonna [__] I'm gonna post a picture of
the guy you know what I mean he's still
in great shape you know sure there's a
little elasticity issues here or there
with the skin but I mean other than that
the guy looks like he can do more
push-ups than I could ever do I hope I
look that good at his age you know when
he still got that beautiful Marcia Brady
[__] a haircut gorgeous hair
oh god I was jealous anyways the band
absolutely [__] smashed it he was all
over the stage it was it was [__]
incredible man it was just at just an
absolutely amazing night and then me and
Mia finished it off as much as I'm
trying to get in shape one of the great
things to do out here in Los Angeles is
to hit your favorite [__] taco truck
a late-night taco spot it's just the
best and there was one I got a buddy of
mine another comedian Forshaw who's like
a connoisseur of all the taco trucks so
I was basically guy
we're down just east of the [__] one
west of the 110 you know and like
Beverly Boulevard what do you got any
[__] he gave me like three taco
trucks like google-mapped all the way
back to my house and we ended up
stopping off at one and [__] I didn't
get any tacos actually got a goddamn
quesadilla which is the classic default
white guy order at a taco truck you know
can I get a chicken quesadilla can I get
one of them I'll be technically is that
even Mexican it's just changed with
chicken hell we do that um it was just a
great night and another night where I
didn't smoke a cigar I'm a smoked a
cigar since February 16th and you know
you have a problem with something when
you know the exact date you know of when
you stop doing it you know other [__] if
you just don't give a [__] you just like
you want to go to McDonald's yeah no no
was last time you ate there Wow okay
year that's when you don't have a price
that's that's when if there was an issue
of addiction it's just completely out of
your [__] life but I know the exact
date whose February 16th I know where I
was I know what I smoked and I know what
I felt like what I had it and I've been
thinking about it every [__] day and
I'm trying to go on a little bit of a
run here cuz if I don't cut this [__]
out of my life this this summer I will
be a four year smoker like what the [__]
what am i doing so but I've been holding
fast with these uh fast or holding
strong whatever the [__] expression
is I only have two a month all right I
to in January two and a half in February
because I started smoking when it wasn't
lit well and I've got another one so I
have one and a half that nice that's not
bad right
come on you guys aren't doctors
generally speaking I should be alright
my body can handle that don't have
[__] days I mean two and a half to a
month once every 14 days
still [__] stupid maybe I'll just go
down to one a month I want to be special
occasion guy I figure I'll smoke one at
the Rose Bowl smoke one Super Bowl
Sunday my birthday what else you got
Flag Day then I don't give a [__] about
that
it's bunch of Jewish holidays in
September I am in show business as a nod
to them that'd be really selfish like I
give a [__] right I give a [__] about
you know like I'm actually acknowledging
another religion the real reasons I'm
just looking for an excuse to smoke a
cigar all my Jewish brothers and sisters
out there and a sign of support what are
you gonna do bill huh make a donation in
the Museum of Tolerance no I am going to
smoke a Cuban cigar and honor to all of
your wonderful contributions to comedy
and show business like for a year that
would be perfect right there's not a
[__] doctor on the planet they always
got it they always get that job is just
to rain on your parade I thought if I
went in a sec doc look I smoked for a
year is that bad and big you know well
you know it's you know it's not bad but
they always go ideally yeah ideally I'd
live in a [__] bubble and I would be
breathe perfect [__] air and I would
bring clean water and I have a
microbiota what the [__] are you doing
doc you got to be doing something going
in here taking everybody's blood
pressure all goddamn day looking at
[__] skin tags you're telling me you
don't have an outlet um I don't know so
anyways having settled that probably
smoked one next week but I like this
month this month is going good because
you know I've already like you know my
little the first two months of the year
I really feel like I should my hands
should be shaking as I'm talking about
this is so bad I want to smoke I I had
my first one January first and then
January 8th I had the second one I was
like [__] the month isn't even half over
and I got a white knuckle
the rest of the way and then I did it
again in February I smoked one unlike
the fifth and then went on like this
I guess the sixteenth then I got another
two [__] weeks so now I feel like I'm
ahead of the game because it's like the
tenth if I can just make it to like the
15th you know then I can actually go on
a run and do one every week for four
weeks then white-knuckle it through
April that just sucks how come
everything fun [__] kills you you
know just [__] kills just sitting
around eating goddamn yogurt by the way
you know I figured out what was causing
the train not to leave the [__]
station I became old Billy parfait right
I went down to this juice shop and they
were [__] raving about this you know
this all-natural yogurt with coconut in
it you know all that probiotic has
probiotics in it this is you know this
isn't negative biotics this is positive
pro this is proactive biotin you have
two kinds of bacteria within your
intestinal tract shut the [__] up I put
this stuff in them I couldn't I couldn't
[__] for days I just kept eating it cuz
they down at the juice shack they're
right they kept telling me how healthy
it was and little did little did I know
I was building like a [__] wall
you know what's that city they're in
Greece with all its the whole city's
just a bunch of white walls you know
that's what I was building in my stomach
were you built I don't know it's the
first thing I thought of
I go [__] yourself you know I'd like to
see you not [__] for three days and try
to dance around it and keep it funny
okay how did I get in this mood
anyways hold on one second hold on Nancy
Reagan died everybody she died and a lot
of people were really upset about that
you know she was a great woman I'd say
you know made her great the shape she
kept herself in considering her husband
had jelly beans all over the [__]
place the fact that she could just say
no to those goddamn things right she
walking around there's something about
being that skinny though after a while
though it's just like you live for
[__] ever but you just you're like a
bird person you know like if she was my
grandmother I would have built like a
giant birdcage
said I hung from the ceiling I just made
make it go in then perch on it you know
I'm not opening the door unless you tell
me I'm still in the will Nancy I guess I
would say grandma Reagan's Greg and all
right this was this but this whole
podcast has gone up the [__] rail so
too goddamn distracted him talking about
putting dead first ladies and bird cages
that's not right is it
he's such a weird fella that Reagan some
people you talk to he single-handedly
defeated the Russians the reality is
didn't come off the [__] bench and he
did he hit the last three you know he
the dagger he put the game away I would
say you know by tricking them into
thinking that we were actually gonna
have [__] up in outer space to stop this
[__] from coming over here you know
that's the weird thing about trying to
bomb somebody from the other side of the
[__] world you're too lazy to fly
over you got to start you got to shoot
them remember Robert Parish is foul shot
you know over the rainbow that's how you
got to do it you actually got to send it
in because of the curvature of the earth
you got to send it [__] up and over
you know what I mean it's like when
you're sitting on the couch and you got
a napkin and you want to throw it into a
barrel but you [__] office chair is
right there you got to go up and over
you know they do that with missiles
somebody actually figured that out
sometimes some super [__] intelligent
scientist guy right as opposed to the
really dumb ones that they put in the
nuclear programs right bill
this guy had just sit there and like
figure that out you know out of our
airspace into the troposphere up into
the stratosphere however the [__] it
goes right out to outer space re-enters
the atmosphere without blowing up right
on the White House nothing but president
right there just sitting there talking
[__]
what a [__] job you know and there's
some other psycho you know they got
cameras in space assumption of somebody
flying around with that DirecTV
satellite on the back of his plane just
falling around Brezhnev and Gorbachev
trying to figure out where they're at so
they always have the exact coordinates
that's what if that's the level of
stress like Obama has and all these guys
that's why they age like 90 years
because they know the other team right
they're going Billy belly check on him
you know they got cameras on you right
on the top of your [__] head wherever
you go you know I'd be all paranoid I'd
be doing [__] head fakes as I was
walking down the hall to the Oval Office
right I wouldn't even go in the Oval
Office I'm not going in there I would
have I'd have a double I'd always be
down in the basement you know ten years
later after I died you know all my staff
would start [__] coming out talking
[__] about me he's a very fearful man
for all the bravado during his speeches
he spent the entire eight years of his
presidency in the the well we're not
allowed to say how far down it goes but
let's just say there's one hell of a
basement under that house
I even think he [__] lives there
there's no [__] way he lives there he
just lives there you ever seen the White
House it's just right there you know he
doesn't live there I bet there's a
[__] you take an elevator that's just
like how much Steve Jobs used to make
those [__] speeches at those nerdfest
right they go down there you know he
come out and he's [__] jeans and no
belt and he just died
[Music]
[Applause]
and all the nerds are like oh my god I
think that's what then he just [__]
Lea nobody knew where he lived right why
why does Bill Gates have a more
reclusive [__] house is the house for
cluesive builders it does the house make
the choice to be introverted whatever
yeah as he has a [__] house no one
could get to I can't get anywhere
[__] near Bill Gates house right but
the White House you can walk right up to
the gate right you can come right up to
it it's gonna put me on a list
I bet what's-his-face I bet Bill Gates
has got a [__] a goddamn you know
remember that's Ted Star Wars thing that
Reagan wanted to put up for [__] you
know the Robert Parish nuclear warhead
rainbow shot from the Kremlin right I
bet he's got those four like drones I
bet he hates drones he's all pissed off
how dare you send my technology I think
he's an evil [__] and that's why
he gives away all that money you don't I
mean it's weird he's like he's like this
sociopath with the heart of gold he's
kind of like Dexter right but if he was
like in the laptops rather than just
cutting up people but it's only the bad
people I was never able to get past that
look at you
god damn you look good yeah yeah
wouldn't be really I think I'd hitch my
wagon to a dog [__] totally
superficial all right you look hot and
you better keep looking hot because I'll
tell you right now I'll go right down to
the used-car lot and I'll start shopping
oh yeah I'll trade you in I'm not gonna
trade you in and about I don't know
you're a classic though you're one of
those those ones that's gonna last for a
while you know imma treat you well
changing the fluids every 3,000 miles
his gross disgusting thank you for
saying that I think I feel like a show
last night
and had some drinks and made some
late-night tacos yes she did
it was so much fun did you talk about
the show yeah how about the confidence
of Iggy Pop going out there 68 has more
swag than all of you [__] why are you
checking the listeners I don't know
hungover you know I don't mean to attack
the listeners I'm just saying
yeah the swag he had out there was the
whole band and Iggy of course is
legendary that was a great show I'm
really glad I went you know I wasn't
feeling up to it but I'm glad it's a
great name for an album to post the post
popped a post pop depression yeah
very good it was awesome and the band
was all wearing custom YSL for those of
you [__] ins what is a designer
clothing YSL is you saying the wrong
he's saying or all you saying are all
yeah so they were all wearing custom YSL
even the roadies like the crew was
wearing like like trousers and ties from
YSL which is pretty dope like Josh
looked great in that suit didn't he
whenever you say trousers I think of
that classic that classic louis c.k joke
when they used to talk about whenever he
does yeah we called phone sexy to always
get that 7 year old woman I'm taking off
you trousers I think we need to bring
cleo's water edition here yeah cuz she's
laying in the Sun why don't you go do
that go grab another mic if you're gonna
be on this no I'm not came in to say hi
Jesus that was one of my favorite dumb
jokes of all time what is a gay horse
eat hey I'm sorry
come on you gotta admit that's funny on
some level alright so anyways what was I
talking about oh I was talking about
Bill Gates swatting away the [__]
drones and having more security than
O'Town there Motown in the [__] maze
home blown yeah pull her out of the Sun
she's done one hike and she's done it's
already [__] hot out here global
warming Nene you're looking [__] good
all right beat him go to the gym keep it
looking good that's part of your
contract show me shut up all right I
[__] hate this whole password thing
you know for the I figured out what the
[__] was wrong with my my iTunes which
is basically I can't listen to anything
that I've downloaded on my [__]
laptop because I have too many other
devices that have already been accepted
by iTunes so I have to deactivate some
others [__] I finally figured that out I
didn't figure it I just went on I went
on the internet I basically typed in
please give me the answer I went there
well you need to go right back to the
Sun Cleo she [__] loves the Sun all
right what else did I want to talk about
all the garage gym is becoming a reality
it's becoming a reality
[Music]
no thanks to [__] rogue fitness Jesus
Christ what an arrogant goddamn company
that is I specifically asked that
company as a celebrity in my mind to
send me a bunch of free [__] for my
garage so that I could then hype their
company to my forty listeners and can
you believe this I hope you're sitting
down can you believe they never got back
to me all right
well because I'm [__] immature I got
to go vengeance now I have to have my
vengeance on that company this is what
I'm going to do I am gonna buy all of
this [__] from them that's what I'm
gonna do and then you know what when
they call me and say hey thanks for
using it I'm not gonna take their phone
call all they're getting out of me is
the price they want for their [__]
goods right
make any sense yeah I don't know I just
threw it out there they never got back
to me I was half serious I don't like I
don't like people giving me free [__]
cuz then they [__] own you on some
level anyways you know hey you know that
time I gave you a chin-up bar I mean
what the [__]
alright I'll give you a ride to the
airport [__] you know you just you just
you can't get out of it you can't get
out of it so anyways I am gonna [__]
do this thing up this is this is this is
the game plan I'm getting that rogue
fitness thing that collapse it you can
fold back into the wall I'm getting a
workout bench you know I'm so excited
for that because I'm so sick of going to
the [__] gym and there's always some
there's always somebody on it
if somebody's always benching right and
I can also do squats and I'll be able to
do pull-ups and then I got my atomic
holds and we're gonna put those above
where my truck is I'll just have to pull
my truck out which I know kind of sucks
but who gives a [__] I'm gonna have an
epoxy floor put in right and then Nia
wants an adjustable speed bag over in
the corner which is great because all
I'll have to do is adjust it like twice
and just like the bicycle I bought her
she's never gonna use it again then I
can just lock that [__] into position
right we'll get it that did it aborted
it beat it up up right I've got to put
it in the corner I'm worried about the
noise you know banging up you know
blowing out my eardrums forget about
that annoying the [__] out of my
neighbors because everybody out here
lives on top of one another so I figure
if I do that and then I'm have those
interlocking rubber things underneath
all the gym area I'll have a place where
I can skip rope right I can do my
pull-ups my only thing is I'm getting
rid of my pull-up and dip station thing
that I have and I'll be able to do the
pull-up still but I won't be able to do
dips so if anybody knows of an
attachment that works just think of just
having the handles coming out of the
wall if they make something like that
which would look really weird for some
reason whatever it's those with that
[__] porno glory Hulse it's like the
glory hole of [__] it's like the
glory hole of workout equipment to just
have like the dip [__] things just
coming out of the wall right
No all right whenever I got a perverted
mind what the [__] do you want from me
how long into this [__] thing are we
23 minutes Michael Jordan all right here
we go here we go let's let's read a
little bit of advertising all right oh
[__] I didn't talk about self-driving
cars I got the biggest argument with
[__] forests Shaw today
oh we were going we never get arguments
we were just [__] heated
he's like a scientist and I'm a dope so
that's just [__] right there that's
just a recipe for it to go off the rails
I brought up force before and if you're
I think he said said he's gonna be in
Nashville soon I'm sure he has a website
he he actually he opens for Jim
Jefferies all the time he's [__]
hilarious like I would go hiking with
somebody who wasn't funny you know what
I mean it's bad enough when you got to
work with the comic that isn't that
funny but if you're gonna walk next to
him for like an hour and a half they'll
tell you that's a rough one here though
all right tracker or track are smart
guys smart phones smart homes technology
has made everything smart Fredo
all right but losing your stuff still
makes mad people feel [__] stupid
tracker makes losing things a thing of
the past
tracker is a coin-sized device that
locates misplaced keys wallets bags
computers anything in seconds just pair
tracker to your smartphone attach it to
anything put it on your dick where are
my balls right next to my day Thank You
tracker you can fight you get it you get
what the [__] it is lose your phone
press a button can't find your nuts
there they are with over 1.5 I hate when
they over explain the thing it's like I
get I got it in the first two sentences
with over 1.5 million devices tracker
has the largest crowd GPS network in the
world so your lost item shows up on a
map even if it's miles away never lose
anything again with tracker
just think if tracker was on everything
no one would steal anything anymore yes
they would they figure out how to go
around
whatever listeners to this show get a
special discount of 40% off your first
tracker device go to the tracker comm go
to the tracker comm and enter promo code
Burpee you are are the hardest thing
you'll ever have to find is their
website oh yeah what about love can you
put this on they're gonna do that in
that stupid dating site with that stupid
piano rude the doodoo and that chick oh
[Music]
this could be the one who makes me a
sandwich yeah that's the longer version
they never show that one alright go to
tracker calm right now and at the promo
code bur for 40% off again that's
tracker comm promo code BRR
why use your brain when you got
technology self-driving [__] cars
self-driving cars are so [__] stupid
one of the great things about cars is
the amount of people that they kill
every year which is great for the
environment and then you have these
[__] robots and everything's gonna be
great I can stare at my smartphone as I
Drive to work
you ever think all these [__] now
what are these robots
you know just decide one day that
they're sick of being the goddamn limo
driver and driving us around they kind
of share a look you know and a red light
and that starts a revolution just like
in the Ukraine where it just took a
couple of jerk-offs on Facebook and next
thing you know all Putin is going you
know what maybe we need to wrap it
Parish a little closer do a little
[__] layup
all right trunk club everybody if you're
anything like me honey then you know
exactly what you like and how it is
snapped to the 12 down to the 6 [__]
except when you're in a the wine aisle I
thought they just said [__] probably
cuz I was doing that [__] hacky gay
accent tannins inter-are O's mean
nothing to you it means nothing to me I
don't even know what they are types of
wine I'm guessing
unless you happened to be a fancy-pants
professional sama leer I know when
people just make somebody like your
fancy pants because you understand
something that takes a little bit of
brains I respect anybody that
understands wine I like those people
they look at it they swirl it around
they shove their [__] honker in there
you know put it in their mouth they let
it swirl around let the different
flavors hey don't you know tasting the
barrel tasting history they let it go
down their esophagus his head stick good
they live across that that woman half
their age they pointed something flashy
and they slipped a roofie in a drink
right they finished the pudding
commercial sorry all right okay where am
I here
okay please include all the following
points during your read I'll do as many
as I can how about that well with club w
club jab yourself driving cars sit for
me I'm special the guessing game is over
Club Debbie don't fall don't fall for
Jimmy already voted for me that's enough
bushes it's the world's only
personalized wine club and your wines
are sent directly to your door not only
just Club W Club W quizzed on which
dining room so where's Dee Braun that's
why I come give your buddy nicknames
send you wine they send you wine that
you will love drinking that's because
club down yeah I can speak Spanish easy
six question quiz figures out your
palates so that so that everybody that
bottle you gets you [__] like Jesus
Christ Club W I got a ranch his read is
lil eating the grape to glass wine
revolution they work directly with the
vineyards to cut out the middleman which
saves you money oh yeah you're gonna pay
those immigrant workers any more money
then you're gonna send some of that
savings they away maybe they can get a
new [__] hat Club W buying a plane or
an aquifer even offers you a no risk
guarantee that you will love what they
said you are your money back and right
now Club W in weapons of mass
destruction it's offering my listeners
50% off your first order and when you go
to Club W Hamel
Prison Club w.com / / wine wine should
be fun not pretentious what why does it
have to take all the [__] class oh I
think it should be a classy goddamn
thing and I think you should take the
time to learn about it if you want to
get into it rather big oh why don't you
use club daddy I was safe during my
watch right why can't you use this thing
to educate yourself why does it have to
all be about taking your hands off the
[__] wheel and letting some robot
pick it out for you free stuff why
should be fun not pretentious evidently
start learning as you drink I guess
they're saying learning is you start
drinking clip WM / / you'll even get 50%
off your first order think about that
turn your teeth gray for 50% off that's
club daddy.com / / alright one more can
you guys sit through this one more
[__] reading here LegalZoom to run a
successful business you need to make the
most of your time and money
good news legal Zhuge can help you save
both during national small business
month I [__] that up but I have the
right voice right Legal Zoom is the
smart way to start your business right
now would you incorporate or form an LLC
you could also save money on some of the
basics to get up and running that didn't
seem like that made sense to me like a
three-month trial on QuickBooks online
accounting software and a domain name
for a year through web.com both at no
charge after your business is set up
Legal Zoom can can help with a lot more
reviewing content contracts and dealing
with day-to-day legal hurdles takes time
away from growing your business
that's what legal zooms business legal
plan is for you get legal advice for
your business from independent attorneys
licensed in 48 states know the lower 48
or are you including Alaska and Hawaii
and maybe not Wyoming and Michigan who
knows you can also get access to NDA's
lease agreements and more the best part
is you won't get charged by the hour
since legal
isn't a law firm instead you pay for low
a low monthly field fee Jesus Christ how
long is this save time and money
starting and running your business
during national small business month at
legalzoom.com today don't forget to
enter bird in the referral box at
checkout that's legalzoom.com
legalzoom.com alright there you go hey
did anybody see that [__] hilarious
Twitter back-and-forth between Kanye
West and a dead male deadmau5 however
the [__] you say his name
I guess Kanye took a screenshot and in
the [__] screenshot allegedly there
was something up there that showed some
website where he was pirating the
software or that [__] DJ guy so huh
what's that oh [__] I got a pause this
near says he might have a leak somewhere
yeah Jesus dad not not too bad just a
little [__] leak the Jay trapped
downstairs I never [__] in anyways so
Kanye took a screenshot and I guess this
ded mile deadmau5 deadmau5 how the [__]
he say his name I'm old I should know
how to say it I guess he made this
software that helps you make an album
and evidently Kanye allegedly had a
website open where you could illegally
download it so he called him out he goes
you're not making enough money to pay
for this software you got a [__]
pirate my [__] and he was just wrote
dick on it so Kanye comes back with the
barrage of [__] just trashing this DJ
talking about his mouse head he got a
fan in there Mike I'm bringing my
daughter she's a big fan of Minnie Mouse
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah just
like just like a corporation you know
just just sending reams of paper over
like on better call Saul trying to
[__] delay it but nowhere in it did
the man deny that he didn't for they
[__] didn't steal it as far as I
could tell he just see just to me and
capitulation just immediately switched
it from you stole my [__] - duh what's
with you [__] Mouse head right I
actually wanted to [__] jump into the
middle of it to give the DJ help because
he kind of was [__] taking the bait
it was just it's like what it chicked us
you know what I mean that they're so
[__] good at arguing that they [__]
they spin you off like you got a dead to
rights and by the time you come through
the whole thing you're like I had a [__]
that I lose it because they they got you
never react to that [__] he should have
just laid back you know on the ropes
let Kanye punch himself out and then
just say yes so like I said you stole my
[__] you know and how does a guy with a
mouse had gonna take shifts from
somebody who wore a leather miniskirt
throughout a whole [__] tour I mean
there was so much [__] he could have
said back but he should have stayed in
the pocket I was just like I was
watching that the way I was watching
like a comedian and a heckler you know
then I was readin I was rooting foot I
was rooting for the DJ for the DJ in
that one provided if did the guy stole
if he didn't either way it was [__]
entertaining you know nice Twitter
battle that nice is it funny how I'm not
into robots driving cars but I like I
like I like I like a good twitter
twitter back and forth you know that's
the Thursday afternoon just before
Friday Monday morning podcast here comes
some music once again we always post at
the mmm podcast Twitter feed will always
tell you what the music is Andrew always
post it I don't know what it is I am an
old man I am just I am just now trying
to update my music oh my god I got to
tell you what I was doing the other day
holy [__] I was listening to I
downloaded all this [__] right
Alabama Shakes [__] love the new that
album that they have was - [__] the
weekend listen to that actually like
that [__] I got to tell you what was
funny though was [__] already forgot his
name I'm Kendrick Lamar I'm so [__]
old help me out here guys I I don't know
anything that's going on with any of
these people Kendrick Lamar I'm sitting
there I have to admit I did have this
old guy thought and I was embarrassed
that I had it I was listening to his
album and I get to
this song and he just keeps going this
dick ain't free right and I'm just and
all I could just kept thinking was this
one a Grammy and I'm not saying it
didn't deserve it but I don't know what
the people look like who [__] vote
for the Grammys but the way people
complain about it and now they're always
giving it to white people right like the
Oscars I'm imagining it's a bunch of
white people in 50s and 60s right takes
a while I would think to establish
yourself enough to even be considered
you know to be on that [__] and I'm just
picturing all these [__] 50 and 60
year old white people just sitting there
listening to this dick ain't free right
like you know like they can relate to
that on some level gonna yeah this is
like connects with me I'm gonna vote
with this you know they probably just
drive down the hood and stand there for
20 minutes and count how many times
somebody drives bike hey free driving
but there's enough people listening to
it we got to give it to them
so anyways but here is the embarrassing
thing I was in I was i listening to I
gotta make sure I say his name right
it's Edie is it Sheehan for [__] sakes
bill you don't know any I did Conan with
this guy he was [__] great I think
he's great I just don't [__] it Sheeran
Sharon will go Sharon and I was
listening to his album and I was this I
was listening to that song one I was
listening to Ed Sheeran one in a Toyota
Prius and I was sitting there going I am
enjoying this like what happened to me I
used to be I and I used to [__]
listen I wouldn't happened but when I
really look back at the [__] that I used
to think was bad as some of it was bad
as stuff a lot of it you know say what
people will say about a sensitive fellow
like this and Eddie here right you know
he does dress like a man unlike the
bands that I listen to in the 80s where
they came up just full
not only did they dress like chicks they
dress like hot chicks trying to hang on
they were really like the first house
real housewives when you look back at a
lot of it you know what I mean I guess
still they were still in that prime in
their twenties I don't know so whatever
those are the album's that I was
listening to this week I literally went
from nineteen seventy eighty to you know
I went from like nineteen I don't know
late 60s to late 80s was what the [__]
I've been listening to for the last I
don't know how many since I worked in a
[__] warehouse in the 80s and then I
immediately went to like 2014 2015 2016
and I survived I somehow survived and I
actually enjoy the [__] so it uh I don't
know I don't know if it's gonna help me
I don't know what the point of it is but
all I know is it's it's I don't know
that's funny to me this dick ain't free
I'll listen to it more I'll try to I
mean it's going into some really white
ears here though it's probably actually
a it probably says more about him as an
artist if I don't get it
you know what I mean then if I get it he
probably doesn't want me to get it like
I don't want some 48 year old white guy
like it my [__] oh maybe I'm wrong the
[__] do I know
anyways [__] off I'll talk to you on
Monday Monday I shut the song
[Applause]
[Music]
hey what's going on as bill burns the
Monday morning podcast for Monday June
14 2010 how the hell are you are you
good
did you have a good weekend did you did
you go down to that place with the thing
I heard it was nice was it nice it is
nice oh that's nice
my son he had a recital this weekend and
we were so nervous he was all a
flustered and more suburban talk about
[__] that nobody cares about course
Frank was in the back with the garden
hose it froze up over the window so we
have to buy a new one of those so you
know Frank course he goes on the
internet and he just starts researching
all about those holes hoses good I don't
can you imagine just Lee is sitting
there at the end of a cul-de-sac like
that is your [__] reality rather than
having a wine cellar I would have just
have a secret room of [__] porn with
Kleenex for me neither rub one out or
just sit there crying at what what
became of my life honey can you go out
and fix his bicycle No
why doesn't he go climb a [__] tree
Jesus Christ what did they do in the
1800s you wonder why the environments so
[__] up that's it right there
everybody you just don't want to go out
and be a part of your kids lives I don't
that's why I told you I enjoyed condoms
I didn't enjoy condoms I just didn't
want to bust one in you without one on
and now I did and now look at it look at
my face sweetheart can't you see the
misery [__] him
well he half looks like you you go fix
his [__] bike I'm not yelling um no
I'm not
[Music]
advice don't take [__] from anybody
watch your mark bill sometimes you and
your podcast with go [__] yourselves and
don't take [__] from anyone well let me
tell you my story back in November a cop
pulled me over roughed me up was a huge
[__] and wrote up every rinky-dink
e-ticket he could not ok now wait a
minute what happened you were just
driving down the street and this guy
just pulled you over I need a little bit
of the backstory here was this guy did
you know did he get into a big fight
with his wife and then took it out on
you
or we did you say something wise to the
guy and he said all right I'm not in the
[__] mood
anyways let's see if we could figure it
out here at the end of the altercation I
shook his hand look him straight in the
eyes and gave him that look that says I
will see you in court [__] I showed
up in court this Monday to defend myself
my plan was to stand before that [__]
and having him explain his actions to me
in a court of law yeah dude this ain't
gonna work out unless she had a witness
I wanted to ask him even then that
doesn't work out I wanted to ask him if
twisting my arms so much that I couldn't
use it for a few days was justified I
want to ask him why he decided that me
5/6 175 pounds was a threat to him 6
foot 2 6 foot 3 250 that he need to hit
me from behind dude call me an [__]
but I'm not a hundred percent buying
this story because you didn't say what
happened before this this guy just did
this is this guy like the [__] worst
cop ever I don't know here we go I
wanted to I wanted to know why he needed
to demean me while I was handcuffed in
the back of the paddy wagon I then
wanted to ask him how many excessive
force complaints he had against him the
answer is four of [__] so I'm wrong here
I wanted to ask him how his marriage
ended his ex-wife has a restraining
order against him for domestic violence
all right I tap out you're right you're
right sorry I wanted to ask him what
part of protect and serve did he not
understand I wanted to end the
questioning with him explaining how he
got caught on a cell phone camera
assaulting a motor
you can look up the video on YouTube
under Milwaukee police Lambo driver la
MBO driver here's what sucks in
Milwaukee if the cop that wrote you the
ticket this doesn't show up in court
your case is dismissed and you don't
have to pay anything
well guess guess why I told you that the
piece of [__] didn't show up in court
ah that's awful I need advice do I let
this all be water on the bridge why do I
take this [__] down I really want
justice but I don't want to be beaten by
other cops what should I do
[Music]
well I think you just shed some light
Milwaukee police Lambo driver all my
listeners will probably look up and
watch that now this guy sounds like a
dangerous guy look you know this is what
I would do if I was gonna try to take
this dude down what I would do is you
know what the local news loves doing now
they love showing like YouTube videos
and they love talking about Twitter and
all that type of stuff because they're
desperately trying to get the kids and
people because they're losing all this
viewership to to the Internet so the
fact that you you have this
controversial thing you have this [__]
up law and you have a YouTube video of
this guy that makes that's like one of
those perfect little pieces you know
coming up next Milwaukee police officer
a little out of line check out the
YouTube video that everybody's been
talking about all the alerta' you mean
you can go that way but yeah I mean
you're taking a you're definitely going
to take a [__] risk you know taking
the Rodney King died this week and that
brought up that whole video and all that
type of [__] and I know you know the guy
just pulled over that's what you're
supposed to do I know I mean look who's
kidding no Ronny King was gonna get beat
down no matter what I mean if you've run
from the [__] cops I don't give a
[__] who you are you got to get beat
down but if you get back up you charge
them a couple times
abso-fucking-lutely but you know there's
got to be a way to take a guy
without giving them 12 [__] skull
fractures you know what I'm saying
it's if I don't know it's a it's it's
it's it's a [__] thankless job and
then it's a really dangerous job if the
wrong kind of person gets uh gets the
job why did my phone just go off oh
that's right I can I do that ship so I
know a person I can't I can't ever watch
that Rodney King thing again that's like
[__] it's the most brutal thing ever
and actually when you watch that now you
go thank God they got [__] what do
you call those things taser what are you
clear what do you call those things what
do they call those things that you they
just uh they zap you you guys ever see
that one that one were they the cop what
the [__] do you call those things he got
tased he got [__] is it a Taser
Cleo why am I so dumb huh [__] love
this dog you know that Cleo um
underrated having a dog it's the best
[__] thing ever anyway since I got I
got to get you this YouTube video now
that I brought it up it's uh it's
basically they're doing a demonstration
of one of those [__] things whatever
the [__] you call them that I just can't
think that why do I keep saying it's a
Taser I know it's not a is it a Taser he
got tased and I can't [__] it I bike
brain is mush so anyways there's one cop
gonna zap another cop to demonstrate it
to the class and look man I don't give a
[__] how much of a man you are
you get [__] zapped with electricity
you're gonna make a noise most guys go
like I'm they [__] go down a this guy
[__] shoots it at the guy and this
dude sounds like he's like ending an
opera he gets tased he's like just
[__] drums just literally something
like that and drops and I just love how
the cop who shoots them tries to act
like he just didn't scream out like a
little [__] girl
it's hilarious but but getting back to
that yeah dude that's that's a serious
um that's a serious thing and you you
know if this guy really is as bad as
you're saying you know the right thing
is not to let it go the right thing is
to try and shed some light on it and
hopefully that they can get this guy off
the force because he's given decent cops
a bad name
there you go so but your your worries
are definitely you know valid I mean
considering none of those cops during
the Rodney King none of them got [__]
they got they got off he can get off
doing that I mean Jesus Christ you know
that dude who shot that kid on that
platform and in Oakland that was [__]
brutal he's like oh I thought it was my
thought it was my house keys I didn't
realize it was my gun and he [__] got
away with that I'm not trashing cops I'm
just saying I'm not saying they're all
[__] bad but I'm just saying it's it's
a it's practically [__] impossible it
literally even if you have video I think
you have to have the combination of
having video and then you have to be you
have to be a certain level of wealth and
influence because if you're broke you
know I don't think that there that you
know you there's no way they're just
gonna be like yeah go [__] yourself
you're done you know and then when you
add racism into it I mean you're pretty
much pretty much game set match which is
[__] unfortunate so I'm talking about
society way beyond my [__] intellect
so I'm gonna tap out here already trash
[__] hair metal and I'm gonna have
[__] angry psycho cops mad at me
[Music]
all right lights camera dumped bill I'm
a 29 year old guy and recently broke up
with a funny attractive and all-around
great girl oh geez
why sir would you do that you asked all
right um two things
her dad was born without teeth and
you're worried your baby will if you
breed with her or she has got something
going on in a vaginal area some sort of
odor stinky [__] I don't know here we
go well let me tell you this girl and I
have been dating for about three months
and we had a great thing going she's
half afro-cuban half Puerto Rican and
really sexy she had a rough upbringing
but I didn't care because she's honest
easygoing and not [__] like so many
girls I've dated she was a bit needy but
I didn't mind we were out at a bar one
night having a few drinks and I was
feeling pretty good I was looking at a
couple of floozies at the end of the bar
and I asked her if she's ever been with
another woman she coyly looked at me and
said yes good stuff I thought yeah dude
this is a [__] fantasy right here if
I can red Shoe Diaries then I proceeded
with have you ever been in a threesome
with two girls and a guy again she
answered yes okay kind of [__] but I'm
no saint well I couldn't stop there oh
god you're gonna go for the rotisserie
question what oh here we go
here we go strap yourselves in for this
one well I couldn't stop there so I
asked have you ever had a threesome with
two guys she looked down at the ground
and she looked up a bit ashamed ly and
said yes Wow
skank alert I thought I then asked her
one more question I knew this one could
back for what a [__] do you go from here
like throwing the high heat to Albert
Albert pool host I finally asked wait
have you ever been in a porn
she then blushed and
look me in the eye and said yeah I
looked at her calmly and was like oh but
inside I was like jesus [__] christ
yeah as well you should you know those
first couple I mean you can look at
let's break this down here all right
she's been with uh she's had a threesome
with another girl and a guy who get that
that's who gives a [__] right there all
right you already knew she banged
another guy all right but the fact that
she also did it with another girl that
takes a little [__] that tones down
his dick in her [__] right this is how
guys think women I'm sorry all right
that's something that that's something
in the the credit the credit bill why do
you try to talk accounting [__] you're
too dumb all right that one's all right
the two guys thing now you can look the
other way on that maybe if it was in
another state but it can't be in the
same state because if you run into one
of the two guys that [__] you know
we're high-fiving as they [__] bang
they're that mean I don't know about
that one but then the third one she did
a porno I mean ya know that's uh you got
to walk away from that or or you have to
go to NASA to get tested for the latest
[__] STDs I would think and then also
God knows what's going on mentally that
you would do that what I just like sex
no no no there's something going on who
doesn't like sex I know
anyways plowing ahead so she goes so
basically she had moved down to Los
Angeles when she was 20 she's now 25 and
after a short stint in the military
somehow she got into the porn industry
for eight months
she did everything ooh [__] sucked the
whole shebang I asked her if I could see
her video but she wouldn't tell me her
performer name and said Viet Lee that it
would be impossible to find her body of
work I asked her why she got into porn
and she replied
cuz I wanted some feeling in my life and
then he writes dojis yeah dude
this poor girl something happened to her
the thing was she was clean had a good
job and I really liked her and the sex
was great yeah obviously you know it's
funny there was something you wrote the
beginning where I just thought she was
gonna be good twenty-nine-year-old guy
attractive all-around great girl oh the
fact that you said she had a rough brain
upbringing but she was easygoing and
honest and not [__] right that was
like that girl's good in bed
that just seemed like a kind of free
open person I don't know I didn't know
she was gonna be that open anyways the
thing was she was clean and I have a
blood the sex was great but I couldn't
stop picturing her in some sleazy porno
that was probably filmed in some
junkyard on La Brea so I went to ask for
a friend's advice most of my guys were
telling me to dump her my gay friends
told me it was fabulous and that I
should overlook it I didn't even bother
asking my girlfriends because they would
automatically reject her and assumed I
had AIDS there you go keep your options
open so regretfully I dumped her I felt
terrible and obviously didn't tell her
it was because she was a porn star
because she would have been ashamed for
the rest of her life and I was happy
that she was honest with me I've done my
fair share of sleaze but this was too
much my question bill was bill my
question bill was it wrong for me to
dump him for some decisions she made
years ago should I have stayed with her
what would have you've done
oh you don't want to know what I would
have done I'm a [__] degenerate
so let's you seem like a good person
dude
when you're trying to find the person
you're gonna spend the rest of your life
with you have to have a list of criteria
all right you sound like you're still
young so there's no reason to compromise
all right I mean when you get with
somebody like that and you're gonna live
with them and you get with anybody
you're taking on all of their [__]
baggage
all right you're only three months in
and you know people who go into the
poorness industry that you know it's
like people become comedians we're not
healthy individuals okay and that is
like a specific area that I just this is
just my own personal non-medical feeling
that you're just not a healthy person
something awful happened in that line I
just wanted to feel something I mean
something bad happened to her caused her
to wall herself off I don't even want to
try to guess what but you know there's
nothing wrong with anything that she did
personally don't technically and she was
honest with it
it all comes down to whether or not you
want to deal with it all right and if
you feel that you know you want to deal
with it and that there was this sort of
connection that you just had this girl
had to be in your life then you're gonna
have to learn to live with it and get
past it but I would be definitely I
would definitely be concerned with
[Music]
certain mental issues not only she's
insane and then I would also be
concerned with sexual boundaries you
know like would she have any and could
she remain faithful after a while and
when you settled into the seven-year
itch or whatever and you really start
needing to work at the relationship and
it's feeling boring and she needs to
feel something again is she gonna go
back to that leather couch from that
show Martin ma in you know down on fog
in the valley and get banged again I
mean I don't know I don't know that is a
that is you know what that is beyond my
skills I don't know how to tame that
horse I could tell you that right
[__] now I don't have no [__] clue
that's a you know what that's a dr. Drew
question that is a
a classic dr. drew question and that guy
within two seconds will get right to the
core of it I would call I'll call in
Loveline men if you're out here call him
up because that's a that's a great one
[Music]
yeah I guess you'd have to figure out
his has she worked through whatever the
[__] she was working through and now
she's ready to I mean I don't know hey
those are some good-looking girls down
there and she's like yeah they are or
whatever like I mean if you kept staring
and in that direction you'd probably get
you [__] threesome right there so
there's that there's that option the
option that you have is if you're with
her like I think you mean that's that's
a selfish [__] na-na a shallow reason
to stay with somebody long-term that
Jesus I don't know
[Music]
[Applause]
in the corner
[Music]
all right
beef Curtin advice and for those of you
in the States that's a slang for the
hoo-ha beef curtains
do the math think about it all right you
ready okay here we go here's a situation
I have a wonderful girl in my life
wouldn't when she does not a [__] that's
what I'm guessing I'm guessing this is
where it's going I wonderful girl my
life great attitude humor big tits nice
ass and a good family Jesus Christ dude
would marry this girl sure it seems good
for now but I have one issue she also
has some mean beef curtains then he put
in parentheses [__] lips just in case I
didn't know that kind of bugged me
bugged the everliving [__] out of me
whenever we get down to the dirty
business so much so to the point I
looked up some cosmetic surgery that
basically gives the beef curtains a trim
job and beauty's the vagina wow dude Wow
all right now before I read the rest of
this if you're gonna [__] ask me how
to have this conversation like listen
love I love you I love you I love you
family I love you your heart everything
but is there any way you could trim your
beef curtains maybe you can get away
with it because you got that cool accent
I don't know but she has it too so she's
not gonna give a [__] you may pull this
off with some foreign chick anyways um
so he looks up cosmetic surgery to try
on a beautiful either vagina now I know
by now I must sound like a douchebag
focusing on the little things now cuz
women do that to women focus on little
things like did that that's a serious
issue do sex is a big [__] thing but
anyways he says but my thinking is I'm
truly gonna pull the trigger he spelt it
that way and keep this woman all to
myself for the rest of my life aren't I
entitled to have a great-looking vege to
look at for as long as our bodies don't
wrinkle away Wow I know there's a lot of
women a [__] annoyed by this one
yeah what about you a [__] dick and
your wrinkled balls once you get a
facelift for your sac there buddy I know
they're all saying that how can I ever
bring this option up to her without I
knew he's gonna ask me without
completely destroying her feelings or
making her hate me for being so [__]
conscious
thanks for the read now go [__] yourself
all right this is a simple one dude
there is no way you can bring that up to
her without absolutely completely
destroying her feelings so you either
need to accept this or you have to you
have to let her go that's it that's it I
mean I would think that if you actually
truly cared about this girl
now all the chicks are going to be like
underneath all those C words um if you
truly care about this girl I would think
that that wouldn't matter you know and
if she looks the way she she's saying
he's saying that she looks I mean what
are we talking here like how far down
are these things hanging is it like you
know I mean if she got him both of them
Pierce could you'd like do like could
you like it's better let's say could you
be like do you like that Olympic the
[__] is that thing you're on the Rings
could you do that and still swing your
feet up and not hit her [__] are we
talking like it's that bad you know if
you did the iron cross with your head be
inter [__] like how far these things
hanging down hey now what's the deal
with beer gardens all right dude there's
no way there's there's no [__] way
and don't don't do that to her cuz she
can't do anything about that if she had
a problem with her [__] vaginal area
you would have known by now because she
would have been self-conscious and she
would have brought it up the way
sometimes girls do about parts of their
bodies and they are super self-conscious
about their bodies because we're so
[__] visual all right I told you one
time when the first girls ever hooked up
with when I got her shirt off and her
bra off she rolled her eyes and I
thought she was thinking that I was like
oh my god like I'm not doing it for like
she's rolling her eyes like this guy's
lame and I found out later she was
self-conscious about this
her breast so I totally took it the
wrong [__] way I made it all about me
because I'm self-involved so don't do
that to her all right
either you can that that's when you just
suddenly have in your head either you
accept that [__] or you move on but
there's no reason to hurt this person
because you're a shallow [__] like me
alright alright Cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]